this music where do I belong I look so
people watches I can oh I just seems
because she says that's his best that's
her best friend for like a year together
I'll show you the friendship he laughed
along with it she was it kind of looks
like you roll down this is her apology
and this is also interesting because we
get here Meisel it's fine watch Harris
she's embarrassed everybody's not racist
no she's not right him and that gorilla
have the same eyes yeah he does a
puckered that's not a racist thing that
there's a similarity in the eyes I'll
see the skin colors what makes it racist
but okay engine we're all grout or no
yeah here's the apology and then watch
he there's something else to look out
for she start crying
[Laughter]
it's so it's so crazy I'm so fringy it's
so cos crying for
[Applause]
he's like also I'm wide engaged this
isn't a huge issue
I'm a white gay guy should be fine what
too much what did you my out of control
it's a cop now it's a whole thing god
dammit if she goes changing demographics
like he goes changing demographics in
she cuz we you shut up you gorilla you
shot a bird the demographics you hate
that would be funny to be funny fried
they can't be [ __ ] apologizing she was
just crying but also started getting
super racist she's like I love him he's
my best friend but we're different
people are different that's all oh god
I'm out listen man people are people
really on edge he's not mm me 19
guerrilla black dye she's like the
similarity the eyes it was just a crazy
talking to a friend you might say that
to your friend but then you're on air
and it's just something we sold to guys
you should know that oh that she's so
comfortable with him well alright we get
him pitching the whole [ __ ] black he's
like the demographics is changing and I
started GoFundMe yeah for a new gorilla
exhibit I want to thank the Nation of
Islam
they serve Islam they're both in a bad
situation yeah it's our fault
they're both in an awkward embarrassing
situation [ __ ] yeah this [ __ ] world
and it's all about it's it's these
people on Twitter who just had some so
much control and it got the one but
corporation let's [ __ ] listen of
course they listen listen yes and you're
fired he's taken down answered you get
canceled right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]